[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel
berichte und christian sievers
guten abend hinein das wort des jahres
in deutschland wurde heute gekürt es
heißt
wellenbrecher bisher dachten wir da an
nordsee frische oder französische
atlantikküste
es waren schöne gedanken das hat sich
geändert
wellenbrecher ist das was deutschland
gerade versucht mitten in der vierten
welle wir haben keine zeit zu verlieren
sagte der chef des robert koch-instituts
heute keinen einzigen tag während sich
die bundesländer daran machen die
gestern beschlossenen scharfen
einschränkungen vor allem für ungeimpfte
umzusetzen patricia wiedemeier hat mir
es ist seine wohl letzte
bundespressekonferenz als
gesundheitsminister und iren sparen
hätte sicherlich gerne bessere
nachrichten gehabt aber mitten in der
vierten welle bleibt ihm nur die
feststellung dass ist so schnell keine
besserung der korona lage geben werde
trotz der gestern beschlossenen
maßnahmen den bereits infizierten helfe
das nicht deutschland wird die zahl von
über 5.000 19 patienten auf den
intensivstationen deutlich noch in den
nächsten tagen wochen übersteigen die
lage auf den intensivstationen wird also
wenn die maßnahmen greifen
rund um weihnachten ihren traurigen
höhepunkt erreichen auch von lkw chef
wieder keine guten nachrichten die
kliniken die gesundheitsämter und die
labore seien überlastet konkrete zahlen
daher kaum möglich im moment gibt es in
deutschland geschätzt und
926000 aktive fälle das heißt etwas mehr
als ein prozent
der gesamten bevölkerung ist zurzeit
infiziert und wir gehen von einer
untererfassung von etwa faktor zwei bis
drei aus und in diese notlage in ein
platz jetzt noch die neue variante
omikron
wir können omikron noch nicht genau
einschätzen aber klar ist dass omikron
in deutschland angekommen müssen und es
könnte sein dass nikon ansteckender ist
als alle bisherigen varianten sowie la
impfen und kontakte beschränken das sei
nun angesagt gestern abend wuppertal
hier kontrolliert das ordnungsamt
bereits auf die verschärften maßnahmen
zb die 2g flicht in der gastronomie
wirklich eingehalten werden wir haben
jetzt bislang insgesamt acht verstöße
wobei man dazusagen muss dass gegen die
jeweiligen betreiber natürlich auch ein
ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren eröffnet
wird weil die ihrer aufsichtspflicht
sozusagen nicht nachgekommen sind die
maßnahmen müssten konsequent und für
längere zeit durchgesetzt werden dann
könnten die zahlen runter gehen aber nur
dann warnt der rk ii chef wenn da die
zahlen wieder runter gehen und wenn dann
die maßnahmen wieder gelockert werden
dann werden sie wieder steigen ja nur
das schon mal vorweg gesagt um genau das
zu verhindern fordert bayern inzwischen
ein komplettes zuschauer verbot bei
fußballspielen und hat es selbst
beschlossen ein umstrittenes thema
gestern bei der bund länder runde
alle menschen müssen sich beschränken
viele wirtschaftsbranchen helfen mit ich
finde dass der profisport der von
akzeptanz der zuschauer und vom rückhalt
der fans lebt übrigens nicht nur die ins
stadion kommen sondern von der
kundenakzeptanz wäre einsicht und
mitmachen ein gutes signal auch der
präsident der bundesärztekammer fordert
weitergehende maßnahmen ich hätte mir
vorstellen können dass man die 2g plus
regel also testungen auch bei geimpften
und genesen durchführt zum beispiel in
clubs und bars zusätzlich oder in
kleinen restaurant zusammensitzt und ich
finde dass mal ein fußballspiel und
großveranstaltungen für gewissen
zeitraum hätte ganz aussetzen können
weil ich denke dass diese maßnahmen noch
helfen könnten das pandemische geschehen
ein bisschen zu begrenzen
31 mal war jens spahn hier in der
bundespressekonferenz während der
pandemie er hätte gerne weitergemacht
seine abschiedsworte kurz und bündig
vor allem bleiben sie gesund
mitte nächster woche endet seine
amtszeit die krone pandemie zu beenden
das hat er nicht geschafft ganz im
gegenteil
der ausgangspunkt für alles was ist die
verheerende coroner lage in deutschland
wie die sich entwickelt im moment und
was mit neuen regeln und einschränkungen
zu erwarten ist darüber sprechen wir
gleich erst nimmt ulrike rödl mit für
einen blick hinter die zahl
[Musik]
seit ende oktober geht die zahl der
neuinfektionen in deutschland steil nach
oben seit november meldet das
robert-koch-institut täglich neue
höchststände deutschland in der vierten
welle bei der bewertung der epidemischen
lage wird dabei unter anderem auf drei
werte geschaut die sieben tage incidents
der erwerb und die hospitalisierung rate
diese werte beinhalten allerdings
schwankungen und ungenauigkeiten denn
erstens die sieben tage incidents ist
ein mittelwert einige landkreise zeigen
extrem hohe andere relativ niedrige
instanzen und das rk ii braucht für
diesen mittelwert die gesundheitsämter
die sind allerdings überlastet und
kommen kaum oder gar nicht hinterher
zweiter der wert ergibt an wie viele
menschen ein infizierter im schnitt
ansteckt ist ein schätzwert auch er ist
also ungenau
drittens die hospitalisierung rate hier
fällt die zahl oft niedriger aus als sie
tatsächlich ist das mitunter mehrere
wochen dauert bis die krankenhäuser die
aufnahme von corona patienten weiter
melden können dennoch zusammen sind die
drei werte zumindest ein anhaltspunkt
wie fest deutschland in der vierten
welle steckt
drei tage lang ging die sieben tage
inzidenz leicht zurück heute dann wieder
leicht auf in manchen landkreisen
scheint der aufwärtstrend gestoppt zum
beispiel in bayern scheint denn ob es
sich hier wirklich um ein abflachen der
vierten welle handelt das ist unter
experten umstritten
professor dirk brockmann von der
berliner humboldt uni guckt nach vorn
anhand von modellen er beschäftigt sich
mit der ebenso entscheidenden wie
schwierigen phase frage wie wird es denn
jetzt weiter gehen herr professor show
guten abend
gute namen passiert was machen sie denn
jetzt aus all diesen aktuellen zahlen
wann steuern wir auf eine trendwende zu
lässt sich das jetzt sagen
das lässt sich nicht exakt sagen wir
beobachten das genau wir beobachten
insbesondere die kontakte verhalten in
der bevölkerung oder das kontakt
verhalten und versuchen daraus abzulesen
ob man sich halt auf ein abwärtstrend
verlassen kann es ist aber allerdings so
dass wir uns nicht täuschen lassen
dürfen von der bundesweiten incidents
denn das war kann man den beitrag ja
jetzt schon auch raus dass das regional
sehr unterschiedlich ist und so in gänze
dann zu einer apatow führen kann und wir
müssen uns auch an vor einem jahr
erinnern dass schon da in der zweiten
bälle ein plateau erreicht worden ist
und die zahlen noch mal hoch gegangen
sind das ist also jetzt ganz wichtig
tatsächlich kontakte zu reduzieren und
mehr zu impfen mehr zu boostern also
alles zu machen was dazu führt dass die
dass diese räder gebrochen wird kontakte
zu reduzieren das ist ja auch sinn
dieser neuen maßnahmen oder idee der
neuen maßnahmen zumindest von einigen
dieser neuen maßnahmen die jetzt kommen
wie viel einfluss werden in dieser
einschränkungen dieser faktische
lockdown für ungeimpfte haben
ja also dieser maßnahmenkatalog ist ja
erstmal sehr bereit man kann den jetzt
im detail durchgehen und in allen
maßnahmen geht es darum kontakte zu
reduzieren wesentliches element ist
tatsächlich
gruppengrößen zu beschränken also dass
sich menschen weniger in großen gruppen
treffen weil das substanziell auf das
infektionsgeschehen einen einfluss hat
man muss das kam auch in dem beitrag aus
natürlich sofort damit anfangen und auch
das kontrollieren dass das passiert also
das gewährleistet ist dass sich menschen
weniger treffen das hat dann immer auch
einen effekt auf die inzidenz ob das
ausreichen wird plötzlich zeigen das
müssen wir beobachten viel zählt hier
auch auf und gerade auf die ungeimpften
im moment ab da soll der druck enorm
erhöht werden reicht denn das aus was
sie da jetzt aktuell ein neuer
impfbereitschaft sehen also bei denen
die bislang noch überhaupt nicht geimpft
sind
naja es gibt ja zwei elemente das impfen
und die kontakt reduktion natürlich ist
es begrüßenswert wenn jetzt immer mehr
leute geimpft werden aber der impfschutz
der wirkt ja erst in einigen wochen das
heißt jetzt muss auf jeden fall damit
dass schnell runter geht und dann auch
effektiv in einigen wochen auch
hoffentlich weniger die intensivstation
belastet werden müssen kontakte
reduziert werden weil das die schnellste
sozusagen waffe ist im kampf gegen
dieses virus das muss halt passieren in
erster linie jetzt und geimpft werden
muss natürlich auch klar und was ist mit
den zahlen als ist es melden sich
tatsächlich jetzt auch menschen die
bisher nicht geimpft waren und sagen
okay ich lasse mich dann doch impfen
reicht das schon sagen sie da ist
bereits einen trend zu sehen der uns
weiter nach vorne bringt oder müssen wir
da viel viel mehr noch tatsächlich
menschen bewegen
also die impf lücke muss geschlossen
werden und zwar substanziell und
vollständig damit auch nachhaltig wenig
mit weiteren wellen rechnen müssen aber
um die wälle jetzt zu brechen in dieser
vierten welle um hier entlastung zu
schaffen und die instanz zu drücken den
erwerb substanziell unter diesen
schwellwert 1 zu drücken müssen kontakte
reduziert werden und gleichzeitig muss
man natürlich nachhaltig impfen und auch
das muss möglichst schnell passieren und
auch das boostern muss passieren damit
die schwindende immunität bei denen
schon geimpften wieder aufgefrischt wird
jetzt sehen wir haben doch gerade im
film gesehen auf regionaler ebene
durchaus große unterschiede in
deutschland es gibt nicht die pandemie
sondern die ist tatsächlich regional
sehr stark unterschiedlich ausgeprägt es
gibt auch landkreise in denen es bereits
eine positive richtung gibt heißt das
wir müssen das alles überhaupt viel
differenzierter sehen und so eine
bundesweite inzidenz ist am ende gar
nicht unbedingt aussagekräftig
also differenziert dinge anzuschauen das
generell gut und auch in diesem fall ist
das gut so eine sache die wir gelernt
haben ist dass wir früh schnell und
regional differenziert die sache
anschauen müssen wir müssen auch auf die
inzidenz schauen weil das die schnellste
variable ist wir sehen zum beispiel in
nordbayern und einigen landkreisen ja
jetzt der positive entwicklung und da
sehen wir auch in dem kontakt verhalten
schon seit einiger zeit rückgänge dh die
konten werden die kontakte runtergehen
dann wird sich das auch in der instanz
bemerkbar machen wir wissen also wie es
funktioniert und wir haben das im
prinzip in der hand als bevölkerung und
als gemeinschaft können wir dass das
ding knicken aber wir müssen das erstens
wollen und wir müssen jetzt alles machen
damit diese maßnahme möglichst schnell
dann auch in die tat umgesetzt werden
damit wir das schaffen wie viel einfluss
hatte in die tatsache dass auch menschen
ohne dass es politische einschränkungen
gebe bereits sozusagen im vorfeld sich
anpassen also gar nicht erst auf die
politik warten gar nicht doof sind
sondern sagen hey ich weiß was ich tun
muss und sich bereits einschränken
gespürt sehen sie da einen effekt gerade
durch diese menschen
ja das sieht man tatsächlich also das
haben wir auch in der ersten welle
gesehen als die sozialen kontakte und
immobilität schon runter gegangen ist
substanziell bevor es maßnahmen gab das
hat man jetzt auch tendenziell etwas
gesehen in den kontaktdaten also die
menschen nehmen natürlich die gefahr
stärker war es spricht sich herum dass
auch
wenn man geimpftes mann infiziert werden
kann zwar einen hohen schutz gegen eine
schwere erkrankung hat also das risiko
die risikowahrnehmung geht hoch und
damit reagieren auch die menschen aber
wir müssen halt echt das alles zusammen
machen die maßnahmen müssen durchgesetzt
werden damit das möglichst schnell
passiert eine kurze frage habe ich noch
einen professor der biontech gründer
herr sahin geht heute davon aus dass er
seinen impfstoff anpassen muss
möglicherweise um auf omikron zu
reagieren was macht denn omikron diese
neue variante mit all ihren vorhersagen
kann man da sagen die wirft alles wieder
komplett über den haufen
na ja so aus sicht der modellierung von
infektionskrankheiten ist es dann
wichtig irgendwann herauszubekommen ob
omikron
ansteckender ist und welche
ob es den impfschutz aus dem weg geht et
cetera also all diese dinge die jetzt
diskutiert werden sowas muss dann
natürlich in einem modell eingebaut
werden genauso wie wir aus der als
modell ihrer reagieren mussten als delta
kam mit anderen eigenschaften als alpha
oder der wildtyp das kann dann angepasst
werden was muss ich jetzt erstmal
herausstellen wie das ist mit omikron
und auch dann deshalb weil diese sachen
halt passieren müssen wir halt die impf
lücke schließen und auch diese vierte
welle brechen weil jetzt in diese welle
rein omikron zu bekommen ist halt nicht
gut nicht gut um es ganz vorsichtig so
sagen weiterhin viel zu tun auch für die
modellierer leider aus unserer sicht
professor borgmann herzlichen dank nach
berlin für das gespräch
bitteschön und damit hier in der sendung
heute abend zu unserem nächsten thema
das ist rang 1 sie ist bloggerin in
china und wir müssen um ihr leben
fürchten sie sitzt im gefängnis seit
monaten im hungerstreik wurde
zwischendurch zwangsernährt und soll
kaum noch in der lage seien zu laufen
oder auch nur ihren kopf zu heben
langsam hatte berichtet aus wo hahn im
februar 2020 als dort das corona chaos
ausbrach ihre bilder gehörten zu den
wenigen die es jenseits der
staatspropaganda in die welt schafften
chinas führung will aus wo hahn dagegen
eine erfolgsgeschichte erzählen mangan
stört da und bekommt das zu spüren
stefanie schöneborn bericht
du wirst verantwortung übernehmen für
die bilder die du hier machst
tankern die video bloggerin wurde zu
vier jahren gefängnis verurteilt weil
sie hinschaute
wenn du das online stellst du wirst du
zur rechenschaft gezogen
ihr verbrechen sie stellte online wie
china in wannen mit dem ausbruch der
pandemie umging
natürlich bin ich verantwortlich für
alle meine handlungen
diese und viele andere videos werden im
netz verbreitet sowie die aufforderung
jancan freizulassen ihr
gesundheitszustand ist schlecht sie
befindet sich in einem hungerstreik um
gegen ihre verurteilung zu demonstrieren
ihr wird vorgeworfen mit ihren videos
streit geführt und unruhe gestiftet zu
haben
sie wiegt nur noch 40 kilogramm circa
ihre familie ist extrem besorgt um sie
sie macht sich sorgen dass sie den
winter nicht überleben wird wenn sie
nicht sofort auf grund der wirklich
dramatischen medizinischen situation an
der sie sich befindet entlassen werden
china möchte die videos von changan
gerne vergessen machen da sie den
ruhmreichen kampf der kommunistischen
partei gegen das virus in frage stellt
sie wirft den behörden vor die menschen
nicht früh genug informiert zu haben
fragt wo das virus herkommt
die kommunistische partei will das
gesicht wahren sie wollen der welt diese
waren dinge nicht zeigen doch hat
changan genau das gemacht und damit hat
sie die rote linie der kommunistischen
partei überschritten also haben sie sie
eingesperrt
er war mal anwalt und weiß wie das china
von jean ping mit menschen wie kindern
umgeht
2017 stand der menschenrechtsanwalt auch
wegen unruhestiftung vor gericht und
trotzdem welche young nicht schweigen
die kommunistische partei kontrolliert
alle menschen im land wenn unsere stimme
von der internationalen gemeinschaft
nicht mehr gehört wird ist es als hätten
wir nie gesprochen doch sagen wir zu
viel werden wir weggesperrt
in china verschwinden immer wieder
menschen die an journalisten
aktivisten bürger die sich kritisch
äußern oder manchmal einfach nur die
realität dokumentieren für die
kommunistische partei ist das eine
innere angelegenheit in die sich niemand
einmischen darf
das flehen und die forderungen der welt
verhalten bei chinas regierung bislang
ungehört das macht sie nicht weniger
wichtig im gegenteil in zwei monaten
sind olympische spiele in peking
kann selber hat jetzt eine übersicht
über weitere wichtige nachrichten heute
da schauen wir nach österreich nach dem
politischen erdbeben dort tauschte ovp
mehrere spitzenposten aus so soll der
bisherige innenminister karl hammer
neuer bundeskanzler werden außerdem
nominierte ihnen der vw-vorstand als
parteichef der bisherige vorsitzende
kurz hatte gestern seinen rückzug aus
der politik erklärt damit reagierte er
auf korruptionsermittlungen wenig später
stellte auch kanzler schallenberg seinen
posten zur verfügung nach nur knapp zwei
monaten im amt er soll wieder
außenminister werden
der europarat hat ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen die
türkei eingeleitet damit könnte das land
aus der organisation ausgeschlossen
werden hintergrund ist der fall kavala
seit vier jahren sitzt der
regierungskritiker ohne urteil im
gefängnis mai 2009 10 hatte der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte kavala freilassung
gefordert doch die türkei ignoriert die
entscheidung der europarat hat 47
mitgliedstaaten und setzt sich für
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
im kampf gegen hass und hetze wollen die
innenminister der länder messenger
dienste stärker in die pflicht nehmen
auch sie sollen dazu verpflichtet werden
rechtswidrige inhalte an das
bundeskriminalamt zu melden darauf
einigten sich die minister auf ihrer
herbsttagung das vorhaben ziele vor
allem auf die plattform telegramm für
soziale netzwerke wurde die meldepflicht
bereits beschlossen und tritt im februar
in kraft
auch in unseren nachbarländern steigen
die korona zahlen in polen und der
schweiz so stark dass sie ab sonntag als
hochrisiko gebiete gelten schon jetzt
haben österreich belgien und die
niederlande diesen status ebenso wie
viele länder mit denen wir keine
gemeinsame grenze teilen wer aus hoch
risikogebieten einreist und nicht
geimpft ist muss mindestens fünf tage
lang in quarantäne
in berlin hat die polizei eine
kundgebung von impfgegnern und corona
skeptikern verboten sie schließt aber
nicht aus dass es trotzdem aktionen gibt
ursprünglich wollten morgen rund 1000
menschen durch die stadt ziehen die
versammlungsbehörde begründete das
verbot mit früheren demonstrationen auf
denen die teilnehmer corona regeln
missachtet hatten das weglassen des mund
nasen schutz sei erklärtes ziel und
förmlich ein markenzeichen der
teilnehmen
bei unserem nächsten thema drohen
regelmäßig wortspiele wie luftverkehr im
aufwind oder die airlines heben wieder
ab aber das lassen wir mal besser denn
erstens ist die lage nach wie vor
unübersichtlich und vor allem kann sie
sich jederzeit ändern
das zumindest haben flughäfen
fluggesellschaften und deren kunden in
den letzten zwei jahren gelernt der
flugzeugbauer airbus einer von überhaupt
nur zwei weltweiten giganten am himmel
will im übernächsten jahr wieder da sein
wo er vor corona mal war aktuell ist er
mit den auslieferungen im rückstand und
da kommt massive warnstreiks der
deutschen belegschaft für das management
zur unzeit die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter hier fürchten dass sich das
europäische unternehmen stück für stück
aus deutschland zurückzieht thomas walde
berichtet airbus beschäftigte legen in
diesen tagen die arbeit nieder laut ig
metall waren es heute 14.000
massenkundgebungen gebe es wegen des
corona virus nicht airbus will den
konzern umbauen die gewerkschaften
wollen sicherheiten wir wollen mit
diesem warnstreik den druck auf airbus
erhöhen um entsprechend auch die
zukunftssicherung die wir haben möchten
schwarz auf weiß zu vereinbaren weil das
bisher nicht geschehen ist und airbus
zukunftssicherung für alle acht
standorte nicht anbietet wir haben der
ig metall ein attraktives angebot
unterbreitet dies beinhaltet unter
anderem
milliarden-investitionen in die
deutschen standorte
kündigungsschutz und standortsicherung
bis 2025 dass carola virus beeinflusst
nicht nur streik sondern auch die arbeit
endmontage eines a350 in toulouse flügel
und ruder kommen aus werken wie hamburg
hierher einzelteile und rohmaterial aus
der ganzen welt eine abgestimmte
maschinerie die das virus in turbulenzen
stößt
sobald menschen nicht mehr reisen können
schlägt sich das durch bei
fluggesellschaften herstellern und in
der gesamten lieferkette
um seine lieferketten zu schützen vor
was die produktion herunter von 60 auf
40 maschinen im monat gerade als die
produktion wieder hoch laufen sollte
landete omikron
ein fortschrittliches nachteil war
leider ist es nicht vorbei die jüngste
variante taucht in dem moment auf indem
wir den weg zur erholung beschreiten
aber auf diesem weg gibt es einige
hindernisse und das wird jahre dauern
bis sich die industrie vollständig
erholt
hier können kunden aussuchen wie sie
ihre jets ausstatten airbus sagt dass
airlines aufträge verschoben aber nicht
storniert hätten man habe ein polster
von 6500 maschinen und in china und
indien works eine reisefreudigen
mittelschicht heran fachleute sehen
gleichwohl an den himmel voller
ungewissheit zeitung die welt vor fünf
jahren konnte man der luftverkehr werde
sich alle 15 jahre verdoppeln darum
bestellten flugzeuge heute mit der
pandemie da aber diese entwicklung von
etwas länger abkühlung als roadie wob
diese schrauben fliegen in einem airbus
um die welt wie ließ aerospace ist einer
der vielen zulieferer in der region
toulouse drei von 40 angestellten hat
die firma in der krise abgebaut nun ist
sie zu 86 prozent ausgelastet wie der
chef uns stolz zeigt und das werde auch
so bleiben trotz co wird die
bestellungen sind da man muss die
flugzeuge bauen man findet für jede neue
virusvariante bestimmt an den impfstoff
und dann geht das leben weiter
dann zeigt uns herrscht immer eine halle
die abbauen lässt ein zeichen der
zuversicht auch hier spielt co wird eine
rolle die hälfte der investitionen
übernimmt wegen der pandemie der
französische staat
wir bleiben bei der wirtschaft und
schauen auf ein problem dass autokäufer
zu spüren bekommen egal ob neue oder
gebrauchte fahrzeuge sind derzeit
mangelware und das sina mainitz schlägt
sich nicht nur in den preisen nieder
genauso ist es autohändler müssen kunden
derzeit gar nicht mehr mit rabatten
locken das geringe angebot wird der
nachfrage nicht mehr gerecht das zeigt
sich auch in den geringen absatzzahlen
sie sinke den fünften monat in folge
dieses jahr wurden bislang nur rund 24
millionen neue autos zugelassen das ist
das schlechteste ergebnis seit der
wiedervereinigung
bis auf die marke mini verloren deutsche
hersteller 2021 zweistellig audi und
volkswagen jeweils mehr als 40 prozent
mercedes und bmw beide über 30
nach wie vor boomen elektroautos mehr
als 20 prozent aller dieses jahr
zugelassenen fahrzeuge sind stromer die
prämie zeigt ihre wirkung
wer ein neues auto bestellt braucht viel
geduld weil oft vorprodukte und chips
fehlen deshalb steigen einige kunden
dann auf gebrauchtwagen um die
inzwischen aber kaum noch zu kriegen
sind und wenn zu hohen preisen
durchschnittlich kostet ein gebrauchtes
auto rund 18 prozent mehr als
vergangenes jahr die autoindustrie ist
das zugpferd der deutschen wirtschaft
mit satten gewinnen doch anhaltende
lieferengpässe sorgen für ungewöhnlich
viel kurzarbeit bei autoherstellern und
zulieferern der dax geht geschwächt ins
wochenende ein minus von rund 0,6
prozent bei einem stand von 15.000 170
punkten am ende der woche überwiegend
pandemie sorgen und schlechte
arbeitsmarktdaten aus den usa danke sie
nah an die börse
bislang dürfen sechs bis 14 jährigen nur
dann kostenlos bahn fahren wenn sie mit
den eltern oder großeltern unterwegs
sind das soll sich nun ändern künftig
können sie auch von anderen personen
begleitet werden unabhängig vom
familien- verhältnisse
allerdings müssen sie auf deren tickets
eingetragen sein die bahn passt ihre
regeln damit an das veränderte
verständnis von familie und elternschaft
an
er war der letzte noch lebende held des
wunders von bern vorbild und hoffnung
war im nachkriegsdeutschland und doch
blieb horst eckel mit beiden beinen auf
dem boden nun ist der fußball
weltmeister von 1954 gestartet er war
der jüngste und mittendrin im legendären
wunder team von sepp herberger der
pfälzer kostete aber sein abschlag
bleibt bei eckl aus kaiserslautern
hängender zu seinem klubkameraden fritz
walter von dort zur an
[Musik]
wenn man mit span span sich schon mal
weltmeister gehört das ist ein ganz ganz
tolle sache ecke spitzname windhund
wegen seiner schlaksigen schnelligkeit
absolvierte 32 länderspiele und wurde
zweimal deutscher meister mit dem ersten
fc kaiserslautern sportlich bis ins hohe
alter geehrt mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz nun ist er 89
jährig gestorben die fußball welt
trauert
[Applaus]
der letzte spieler der ungarn damals ist
vor sieben jahren gestorben das wunder
von bern lebt weiter und damit
verabschieden wir sie in den
freitagabend und natürlich auch ins
wochenende und empfehlen den spät ins
bett gehen unter eben noch das
heute-journal update mit nah sein möchte
mehr um kurz vor halb eins von uns im
namen des gesamten teams ein angenehm
haben
[Musik]
guten abend das wird ein sehr
winterliches zweites adventswochenende
und das liegt an dem neuen tief frank
das bringt uns regen schnee schneeregen
und ganz gefährlichen glatteisregen und
auch in norddeutschland kann es
spätestens in der nacht auf sonntag
ergiebig schneien heute nacht fällt
häufig regen schneeregen oder schnee und
es kann fast überall sehr gefährlich
glatt seien auf den straßen denn die
temperaturen sinken doch meist auf plus
3 bis minus sieben grad und nur zwei
regionen sind davon ausgenommen hier der
niederrhein und auch die ostfriesischen
inseln da bleibt es wohl ganz knapp zu
mild für glätte und morgen ist es kalt
für die allermeisten von uns die
höchsttemperaturen liegen nur zwischen 2
und 5 grad anders im südwesten da
klettern die werte auf milde 6 bis 11
grad das ist dem starken bis stürmischen
südwestwind geschuldet und so setzt hier
im schwarzwald auch taubertal besonders
gefährlich wird es morgen früh in bayern
wenn der regen auf den noch gefrorenen
boden fällt wird es spiegelglatt morgen
vormittag fällt auch noch schnee hier im
bayerischen wald im oberpfälzer wald im
thüringer wald auch richtung sachsen
berlin und brandenburg das lästern am
nachmittag nach dafür schüttet ist ganz
ergiebig im südwesten und auch am
sonntag gibt es noch schnee und
schneeregen fälle bei 1 bis 5 grad und
montagfrüh zu berufsverkehr sollten sie
sich hier in mecklenburg vorpommern und
dem nördlichen brandenburg auf bis zu
zehn zentimeter schnee einstellen am
alpenrand sind es sogar bis zu 30 cm und
in der neuen woche wird es ganz
allmählich milder guten abend